right now the numbers are on the side of
democrats there will be a reckoning and
an accounting on the 8th of november
of this year we're going to win in
november
that's a lot of bravado given the
headwinds a new poll of the 56 most
competitive battleground house districts
found that republicans hold a four-point
advantage that's 46
to 42 percent on the generic
congressional ballot now in historical
terms that is a massive advantage for
the gop presidential approval is driving
that gap while just 37 percent approve
abide in those battlegrounds 50 percent
approve of trump what's more this is a
latest poll showing that democrats are
losing ground with non-white voters
especially hispanics and asians now the
one red flag for the gop according to
axios
some senate races where potentially
weaker candidates allow individual
democrat candidates to run ahead of
where biden is here now is rick scott
florida senator and chairman of the
national republican senatorial committee
i know this is the fourth state your
home state where where you are right now
with us senator thank you
the senate is what a lot of republicans
are worried about let's start in
pennsylvania where you have john
fetterman who's basically been m.i.a
illness and other things m.i.a against
dr oz who's very well known what's going
to happen there oz is going to win now
all this is tied to getting the money
right uh we've gotta we've got to raise
the money but dr oz uh amendment is a
good guy he cares about the state he's
uh he's working hard every time i talk
to him he's out in some on the camp
campaign trail and fetterman there's
nowhere to be seen but he has nine
million dollars and i think uh it's like
1.5 what the heck where are the
republicans why aren't they giving any
money yeah we we've got to raise our
money i mean that's the democrats always
have more money than us so if you want
to help us you can text win to 55404
but i'm going to do everything i can to
help mimit uh get the money but he's
gonna run he's gonna run a good race
he's a think about he's a hard worker
he's a doctor he cares about people he's
gonna win isn't the best because we
gotta get the money here but isn't the
best campaign argument in all these
races even get it away from the
individual see a vote for the democrat
is a vote for high gas prices
prices high food prices afghanistan
withdrawal open border you name it i
mean this is biden's numbers are
horrible because biden's policies are
normal are bad and and the democrats are
that's how they're voting they're voting
horribly it's bad for the country yeah a
vote for a democrat is vote to vote to
keep chuck schumer as senate majority
leader all across the country
republicans are energized even in
pennsylvania since 1998 this is the
first time more republicans voted in a
midterm than democrats that tells you
something twice as many republican
democrats in ohio 145 000 more
republicans democrats in north carolina
so we're gonna i mean we get the money
we win well you gotta open people gotta
open up their wallets here it isn't the
economy or inflation though that will
matter to voters this november according
to msnbc watch
there are folks that you know would
consider themselves to be conservative
to be pro-life
and yet at the same time they have a
hard time stomaching what they saw
unfold on january 6 and the efforts to
undermine the democracy that have come
after this and so i know that these are
real conversations that are playing out
in households across the country and why
so many people are having a hard time
even determining whether they are
republican
okay senator around the dinner table are
people talking about liz cheney and
benny thompson in january gas prices
food prices open border um you know this
by in how weak biden is that's what
they're talking about they're talking
about family issues they're talking
about why are they teaching critical
race theory by schools why did the
democrats win defund the police that's
what they're talking about one of the
things that i loved about your blueprint
that you laid out you came on the show
and talked about it it was very specific
issue after issue
the concern that a lot of us have when
republicans take power
it's like 30 days of well what do we do
now and the democrats already from day
one this this this this and this are you
guys ready on day one on oversight
investigations legislation well i've got
i'm going to do everything i can we've
got to get ready i put out a plan it's a
rescueamerica.com
uh the we've got to have a plan i mean
we got to teach our kids this is the
greatest country we've got to make sure
we stop this racial politics we've got
to make sure we're going to secure the
border cut taxes reduce regulation
that's exactly what we have to do and we
have to fight for those things new newt
gingrich did it 94 and they had a plan
as soon as they won they went in there
and that's what we have to do because
you know you know chuck schumer is doing
it every day yeah well they certainly
are senator we appreciate you joining us
thank you so much hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else